okay our final Speaker of the day is the
Honorable Edith Jones at dinner last
night she said she favors brief
introductions the briefer the better so
I'll keep to that guideline as best I
can while still keeping in mind her many
impressive accomplishments she was
appointed to the bench by President
Ronald Reagan in 1985 and she became the
chief judge at the Fifth Circuit in 2006
a position she held until 2012 she was
awarded her JD at the University of
Texas law school where she was a law
review editor and received the order of
the coif COI F and I confirmed the
pronunciation with the judge last night
at dinner
judge Jones served on the board of the
Sam Houston Area Council of the Boy
Scouts of America for many years and
received Scouting's Silver Beaver Award
I think that was back in the days when
the Boy Scouts was still an organization
for boys she has been a member of the
garland Walker in of court in Houston
for many years and is its current
president and she currently serves on
the board of the Calvin Coolidge
presidential foundation her topic today
is the rule of law and administrative
law would you please welcome the
Honorable Edith Jones
[Applause]
good afternoon I have to say that after
hearing about Russia and China and how
to think about trade and so on we're
back to administrative law and it's a
rather dry topic it was introduced to
you last night from the standpoint of
the political situation by chemstro
Seoul who put about as much excitement
on it as as possible and then today
Larry referred to it a bit as well I'm
going to my aim is modest and
unfortunately it's law centered because
I'm going to try to put a little flesh
on the bones of what it means legally to
operate under the administrative state
that we have today but first I want to
say a word about Hillsdale I was invited
to teach there about four years ago
I've taught twice seminars for kids
interested possibly in going into law
school and they were very very good kids
very thoughtful very interested in
learning about the legal system as as it
ought to be in my view I was the teacher
after all and I've now had a series of
law clerks who started there and did
their undergraduate career at Hillsdale
and then went on to very fine law
schools whatever one may think about the
quality of legal training in the United
States and I have some real interesting
observations about that the Hillsdale
kids went in with their heads on and
came out well trained to practice and
preserve our Democratic Republic through
their legal training so I am very much a
supporter of the Hillsdale Enterprise
and dr. Arnn and the many faculties I've
members I've had the privilege to work
with well so what is the what is the
problem with the administrative state
you've pretty much heard about that from
Kim Strasse land dr. Arnn
but let me start off by quoting James
Madison I believe there are more
instances of the abridgement of the
freedom of the people by gradual and
silent encroachments of those in power
than by violent and sudden usurpations
the rise of the administrative state has
in fact silently and gradually
encroached on our constitutional
structure for approximately a hundred
years I'm going to trace this history
very briefly outline the type of
challenges that poses and offer just a
few thoughts about what needs to be done
to reverse these encroachments we start
off as we always must with the framework
of the Constitution Article one commits
all of the legislative power to the
Congress who are the people's
representatives and tied to the people
Article two represents the the president
who takes a commitment to makes a
commitment to take care that the laws
shall be faithfully executed so it is
his job to apply the law and enforce the
law through what we organs such as the
Department of Justice and finally
article three is the independent
judiciary blessed with life tenure which
of course I didn't favor until I became
a federal judge and salary protection so
that we have the power of will and not
judgement to say what the law is
independently however you will see how
effective that those protections are
what was the purpose of the tripartite
division of government the separation of
powers as dr. Arnn pointed out it was to
preserve individual liberty within a
framework of law there were 500 years of
English history leading up to the
American Revolution during which
Parliament or the Lords or whoever
struggled to rein in
Kings exercise of unilateral and
unchecked power the royal power was
often exercised through crown courts and
councils which were unrepresentative
bodies they made and enforced the Kings
edict wholly apart from Parliament and
they were predictably arbitrary and
oppressive the founders knew this and
this is why James Madison voiced the
universal view of the framers when he
said the accumulation of all powers
legislative executive and judicial in
the same hands whether of the one the
few or the many is the very definition
of tyranny so we have the structural
Constitution which is intended to
provide have separation of powers to
protect liberty prevent arbitrary and
oppressive government this brilliant
plan worked for over a hundred years
through political struggles economic
changes civil war and the demise of
slavery as of 9th 1892 the Supreme Court
could declare quote that Congress cannot
delegate legislative power to the
president is a principle universally
recognized as vital to the integrity and
maintenance of the system of government
ordained by the Constitution what
happened to this universal consensus
well as you know the late 19th century
posed a number of social and political
challenges to the country there was the
rise of big business mass migrations to
the cities during the industrial age
there were social tensions and upheaval
but just as important and an
intellectual challenge arose to the
foundations of constitutionalism
scholars like then professor Woodrow
Wilson had become enamored of the German
ideas about progress sovereignty and
government social responsibility the
Germanic system elevated social welfare
above individual
Verde and a place at that time what they
said was a scientific efficient brand of
government management over government of
the people and by the people
honest independent expert administrators
the argument went would rise above
politics and pursue the best interests
of the people the progressive movement
which influenced both political parties
at the turn of the last century was
heavily influenced by these people and
these ideas in fact many progressive
scholars believed that the
Constitution's separation of powers was
antiquated and inefficient but they
didn't tell the people that well as the
progressives campaigned they made their
case to the public on more appealing
grounds who could object to the
government's acting through regulators
and administrators to prevent railroads
and utilities from price gouging and
discrimination who could object to
improving working conditions and
ensuring safe drugs meat and food thus
at the beginning through the efforts of
the progressives we saw the creation of
the Federal Trade Commission and the
Interstate Commerce Commission as our
first major regulatory agencies
interestingly in the early years of
their existence they could not enforce
their regulations they had to go to the
article three courts to do that Congress
started passing these laws and
delegating to agencies within the
executive branch and the agencies in
turn were given the authority to decree
regulations with the force of law
that means the administrative state was
born during the Franklin Roosevelt
administration as you all know
administrative agencies proliferated and
that may be why we call the presidential
tenure in the modern era
and administration the these were
created and in response to the Great
Depression but also because these
progressives within the Roosevelt
administration believe that ordinary
politics could not solve the problems of
government and besides that they didn't
want the people to be in or to be
bothered with too much so we had the
alphabet agency era the FPC the SEC the
CA B the NLRB the FCC along with the FTC
in the ICC and others began regulating
major sectors of the American economy
again apart from a few pesky Republicans
and those who had felt the sting of
regulatory enforcement who was going to
object to these agencies who was arguing
that the separation of powers have been
violated
for a time the United States Supreme
Court did that in a most famous decision
it overturned the National Industrial
and eye Recovery Act the NRA in the
Schechter poultry case and mr. schector
the kosher butcher in I think it was
Brooklyn had had been prosecuted with
the threat of being sent to prison
because he was selling chicken too cheap
when that got to the US and by the way
Felix Frankfurter one of the great
liberal term conservative justices was
then advising the Roosevelt
administration he told him don't pursue
this case it's not going to come out
well for you this was the classic
david-and-goliath struggle of the little
man caught in the toils of
administrative excess it's early enough
when it got to the Supreme Court in
Schechter poultry the justices started
asking questions of the government and
snickering during the argument that was
a tip-off
the in Schechter poultry the Court
unanimously held that Congress had
delegated its legislating power to the
executive in an unlimited fashion what
called the non delegation doctrine was
violated and the NRA was effectively
dead that is the last time the Supreme
Court declared a law unconstitutional
for violating the delegation principle
during the Roosevelt administration
statistics tell the tale of the growth
of the administrative state from the
Frant founding until 1917 agencies were
created with the power to determine
private rights and obligations by
rulemaking or adjudication in the next
thirty years 1900 to 1930 the port of
the mostly progressive here except for
Calvin Coolidge an additional 17
agencies were created in less than a
decade from 1930 to 39 18 more agencies
took off wage and price controls during
World War 2 together with abuses
perpetrated by these agencies aroused
the public and influenced even the
Democratic Congress and president and
eventually public pressure led to the
enactment of the Administrative
Procedure Act in 1946 the APA is still
enforced today still allegedly governs
rulemaking and the actions of
administrative agencies in broad terms
the act was supposed to accomplish four
goals first to keep the public informed
of agency organization procedure and
rules second to foster public
participation in rulemaking that's a
good idea
third to set uniform standards for
rulemaking and adjudication an
adjudication is when an
agency decides whether a member of the
public has violated its rules and
finally to define the scope of judicial
review of agency action senator McCarran
a sponsor of a bot of the legislation
called the APA a bill of rights for
hundreds of thousands of Americans whose
affairs are controlled or regulated by
federal agencies as the framers knew
power without accountability devolves
into authoritarianism accountability in
their design arose from the rule of law
and the separation of powers did the APA
standards achieve the goals of the of
the legislators and legal accountability
for administrators and regulators but
sadly in my view it did not take for an
example the Occupational Safety and
Health Act which promulgates regulations
for workplace safety what I'm going to
list is what how an enforcement action
proceeds under OSHA but it is
characteristic of the operation of
almost every administrative agency
number one OSHA can come to a workplace
without a warrant and look at all the
records and workplace and and examine
that workplace to its heart's content
number two it can base charges on policy
statements or interpretation of its own
regulations that the regulated party or
workplace owner may not have quite
understood because they weren't clearly
written down number three
based on this warrantless search and
charge with no underlying discernible
written policy they can issue a citation
and a fine well what can the business do
he can go in
to court but the court is an OSHA Court
an administrative law judge and what
happens there there's no jury the
aminute and the employer instead of
having the presumption of innocence the
employer has to prove himself innocent
he has to prove he did not commit this
is what the IRS does too by the way you
have to prove that you don't owe the
taxes and what if you lose before the
administrative law judge oh you can
appeal to whom the Occupational Safety
and Health Review Commission which made
the unarticulated policy and authorized
the warrantless search to begin with
does this sound fair to you does this
sound like the rule of law but this is
in fact under the APA this is the way
most agencies are still allowed to
operate well what about the role of the
courts in policing the agencies that's a
very interesting story let me read you
the standards of review for judicial
action courts can overturn regulations
if they are quote arbitrary and
capricious and abuse of discretion or
otherwise not in accordance with the law
close quote does this sound clear to you
well your laymen for the most part but
believe me lawyers have struggled with
the meaning of these standards and in
any event they're clearly established to
favor the administrators so going into
the courts the regulatory body has a leg
up on its interpretation of the law and
the regulations and the procedures that
are used in addition if the agency took
its action by means of an adjudication a
trial-type proceeding it can defend on
the basis of quote substantial evidence
well here's another legal explanation
substantial evidence is quote more than
a scintilla but less than a
preponderance
so they can be completely wrong but if
it's more that they do not the agency
does not have to prove up the facts even
to the standard of a civil trial much
less to you know the criminal standard
beyond a reasonable doubt so under the
APA and up until this late 60s a vast
amount of complex economic
decision-making occurred within this
agency framework and I say economic
because most of those agencies were
regulating the organs of interstate
transportation utilities Commission's
communications and financial services as
far as the standards were concerned
astute commentators like Judge Henry
friendly who was the mentor of Chief
Justice Roberts complained that the
open-ended and vague standards of
judicial review resulted in conflicting
and unpredictable decisions out of the
courts so the courts occasionally might
have reversed regulatory decisions but
they certainly added to the length and
complexity of the of the decision making
well then we come to the year of Lyndon
Johnson and Richard Nixon their
administration's approved the creation
of regulatory statutes and bodies that
became oriented toward even vaguer
objectives like risk reduction social
welfare in the environment Congress
commissioned the FDA to approve drugs
and medical devices it created the EPA
OSHA Consumer Product Safety Commission
it instituted auto safety regulations
authorized Medicare and Medicaid which
for the first time were regulating
doctors and hospitals and ERISA was
passed to secure employee pensions
regulators were granted virtually
unlimited authority during
age in lawmaking adjudicating and
penalizing according to their respective
mandates and to avoid the agencies being
captured by the end by the groups that
were being regulated Congress began
adding citizens suit provisions and of
course what is a citizen suit provision
worth unless you're going to ship the
fees to the citizens who win in the
lawsuit create a great enticement for
even more litigation and delay just to
show you how the inability of the courts
to respond was occurring here justice
Byron white addressed an administrative
conference early in the 70s and he
pointed out in the 1960s the Supreme
Court received cert petition in about 60
administrative law cases each year and
it decided 30 of them by the early 1970s
the number of petitions had increased to
several hundred but the Supreme Court
was still deciding only 30 such cases
today I dare say it's deciding even
fewer state such cases but the amount of
federal regulation has mushroomed up I
would venture to say seven to eight
times the volume of litigation that
existed in the early 70s so the courts
physically can't keep up with the growth
of the administrative state even if we
thought we could do something curiously
the Supreme Court while pursuing
judicial activism toward the Bill of
Rights began to adjust to the
administrative state with inconsistent
pronouncements on the one hand
Mandira pre-enforcement review of
regulations in other words it speeded up
the process by which parties could enter
into the federal courts and challenge
regulations
instructed the courts to make a thorough
in-depth probing review of the factual
record underlying agency action but I
think far more important were series of
decisions that lead agencies run
according to their own devices or in it
or possibly run amok in a pair of
decisions around 1972 the court
encouraged agencies or authorized
agencies to go into what we called it a
notice and comment rulemaking and that
is the kind of rulemaking where the
agency files a public notice and the
federal registry register we're thinking
of making a regulation that will you
know take care of whatever we're going
to whatever it is you know finance some
financial rule and an interested parties
are given 30 to 60 days to comment and
then 120 days later perhaps the agency
comes out with its proposed rule
agencies could the parties can come in
again and then the agency promulgates
its rule it has very little to do with
the with the actual legislative process
as we would have through Congress you
have an agency that may or may you know
that sees its goal in life as
single-mindedly pursuing such and such
type of administration and doesn't take
the holistic approach that Congress has
to take in the ordinary democratic
process but noticing notice and comment
rulemaking was quicker and more
efficient and device which is fine if
you want to extend regulation which is
what the Supreme Court essentially did
they also had rebuked the DC Circuit DC
Circuit was in a frenzy of imposing
additional requirements on this notice
and comment rulemaking
for doing that they told the courts that
lower courts you cannot second-guess the
basis when the agency goes out to
prosecute someone in other words what we
call prosecutorial discretion in the
hands of the President and the DOJ which
is accountable politically prosecutorial
discretion is a very important thing in
the hands of the agency there is no
political accountability because many of
these agencies are deliberately
structured to have no direct
accountability through the president and
finally in 1984 the Supreme Court issued
what the Chevron decision which if
anybody's interested in a room full of
paper has been spilled over the benefits
or detriments of the Chevron decision
but the bottom line was it told courts
that we have to defer to an agency's
reasonable interpretation of ambiguous
statutory language well all I can say
about that is that Justice Scalia's
career was devoted to the principles of
originalism in the Constitution and
textualism in interpreting statutes and
were it not for Justice Scalia courts
would be free to hold that every darn
statute is ambiguous and they and the
regulator's therefore had free run of
the entire Code of Federal Regulations
it is only thanks to Justice Scalia I
think who made every judge focus on what
the text and context of statutes
actually say that in some occasions we
were able to hold the agency to account
against the law like duh but what
happened the bottom line here is that
the Supreme Court combined with these
relatively latitudinarian standards of
judicial review deprived courts of the
ability to
rigorously review regulations so again
what does this mean for the rule of law
well it seems pretty clear and what
happened and how did the agencies react
well predictably they have been able to
they've deliberately exploit ambiguities
and regulations the the I you know if
regular sorry if it's statute is truly
ambiguous then they do have every
ability to promulgate a reasonable
regulation reasonableness is generally
in the eye of the beholder and most
judges are quite reluctant to say that
regulation was unreasonable they are
allowed to even bypass notice and
comment rulemaking and it became very
common in the last fifteen to twenty
years to substitute even formal
rulemaking with a fig leaf of public
participation to policy statements why
because the Supreme Court said that when
an agency interprets its own regulations
we have to give great deference to that
now that's a principle that's coming
under serious attack now but at the
moment that's the law so why bother with
a rule making when you can just issue a
policy statement and as you all know
what this stuff is called dark matter
and what's the impact of dark matter
well with such policy statements the
regulated parties know what they have to
do so that they won't be brought hauled
into a proceeding by the administrator
it's an offer that most regulated
parties can't refuse this deters this
also deters legal challenges and
insulates the agencies from oversight
predictably the regulator's went to
excess there are too many examples to
name from the past decade but I'll try a
few there was the guidance letter that
force high schools to consider adopt
same-sex bathrooms it was a Dear
Colleague letter that motivated the
educational institutions to abandon due
process standards and seriously water
down the definition of sexual harassment
the you may have read about problems on
college campuses conscience clause is
protecting medical and religious
personnel from federal regulations were
abandoned under presidential influence
the executive agencies awarded
exemptions contrary to the plain terms
of the Affordable Care Act so that
special interest groups like moi the
federal judiciary and Congress are
exempt from Obamacare and believe me our
premiums are a lot lower than yours are
and President Trump had threatened to
take that special privilege way one time
in it I can't imagine why he hasn't but
that's the way it is another example of
special privilege in Theed the arrogance
of the agencies is quite astounding the
Consumer Financial Protection Board
which OMB director Mulvaney took over a
couple months ago has built a hundred
twenty million dollar building and prime
prime property in DC it costs $400 per
square foot and the article on it said
that it was look more like an upscale
headquarters a camera or a fancy hotel
this this cost per square foot was more
than Trump World Tower the agencies also
felt free to regulate again you know
even beyond the statute Kim Kim's
Drossel mentioned this last night one
example was united air regulatory group
versus EPA where they took a statutory
threshold of 250 tons of air pollutant
and turned it into a hundred
tons so that they could so they could
further their interest in regulating
greenhouse gas
it was pretty not difficult although it
was a 6-3 decision of the Supreme Court
to say an agency can't rewrite numbers
in a statute for a 20 or 30 years the
IRS has been evading laws that require
agencies to provide cost-benefit
analyses of their regulations and
finally preparing for these remarks I
read an article in the Administrative
Law Journal which goes out mostly to
people in the administrative agencies
commenting that a dominant tendency in
public administration training today is
simply to disregard the rule of law
issues and the author says hopefully I
think this is something that
administrators really ought to think
about you know that in other words that
they're working for the people under the
rule of law so on another level
regulatory agencies began overturning
decades-old precedents in order to
fashion policy this these kinds of
actions have led to great uncertainty
which undoubtedly had an impact in
deterring economic growth recently
suffice it to say and I think you've
already gotten some numbers here just
for an example of regulatory groups
going crazy in 2015 the federal
government promulgated over 3500 rules
and in 2016 over 30 850 new formal
regulations were issued I think this
really came home to a lot of the
American people when the Supreme Court
decided the Sackett versus EPA case the
Sacketts had bought a 2/3 acre parcel I
think in I Idaho or Utah near a lake to
build a retirement home and EPA swooped
down on them and said this is a wetland
well
they were above the lake but they were
doing some fill work and said this is a
wetland and if you don't stop this
you're going to get sanctioned $10,000 a
day and hey you can't go to court well
fortunately the the Supreme Court said
due process hasn't been totally
abandoned and that they could had the
right to fight the propriety of this
decree in court before they might
actually have to pay $10,000 a day so
from all these sand points the
administrative state has expanded with
little control being exerted even during
the Bush and Reagan administer and
Reagan administration's and as this has
happened
it is also eroded the actual tripartite
organs of our federal government in
other words Congress has been accustomed
become accustomed to delegating more and
more unaccountable power out to
bureaucrats and there are many reasons
for this but just a couple of really
troubling examples are the in the
sarbanes-oxley bill they created the
public accountability public accounting
oversight board the piece PCAOB the
constitutionality of which went to the
Supreme Court why because they insulated
that by two levels from the appointment
authority of the president why did they
do that they did it so that that board
would not be politically accountable for
the for the accounting standards that
was setting up dodd-frank may have
epitomized the idea of delegating
regulation amuck it says it sent
instructions to a couple of dozen
different federal agencies so far over a
hundred thousand pages of regulations
have been issued in pursuance of
dodd-frank one private research
Institute found that for an affected
business to learn how it needed to
comply it couldn't ask anyone to read
the regulations it had to do a computer
word search now this the rule of law
means that the law has to be
intelligible at some level and I would
say that if you need to do a computer
word search to find out how often your
local financial adviser has to fill out
forms to comply with dodd-frank
something is seriously amiss the rule of
law has been forfeited Congress had
every reason to know what it was doing
but so the the practice of legislating
has been eroded the courts oversight of
administrative state can hardly keep up
with the volume of new regulations we
are hindered by the current APA
standards and by the decisions I've told
you more than that there's a problem
that Tocqueville noticed about lawyers
which is that he called lawyers the
aristocracy of the United States and at
one time I used to naively think that
was because we were solar nerd and
well-trained but there was another side
to his comment and that is that lawyers
are most inclined to favor the status
quo and to be happy to work with
whatever executive power there is and
that includes that includes the
presidential power and whatever the
status quo is in the organization of
government at a different time well
judges are of the same breed so I've
already told you how the ex executive
branch has fared during this time the on
one hand the administrative agencies
have become bloated and very much
profited in terms of being able to act
independently and without accountability
on the other
and there are so many people within
those agencies as Kim Strasse was
describing that a new president can
hardly keep them under control and in
fact in many instances they're able to
pursue their own devices in resistance
of the executive administration what
what can we do
well can't there are a number of things
Congress can do and various statutes
have been proposed to even reform the 76
year old or 71 year old Administrative
Procedure Act they several of these
passed the House of Representatives and
then died in the Senate a real easy
answer would be just to cut cut the
budgets of regulatory agencies which is
something that I've suggested that
scholars sometimes and they just sort of
roll their eyes and how naive can you be
but you know if you don't have as many
employees you're either going to have to
focus on your mission or else make it
plain that you're that you are not
acting in the people's best interests
they could aggressively continue to
aggressively use the Congressional
review Act I will shout out my former
law clerk Todd got siano who worked for
congressman David McIntosh to pass the
Congressional review act 20 years ago
and until January of last year it had
only been used once to stop the
enactment of extreme regulation there's
another measure called the reins Act
which is pending I do note that
regulation of these economic when I
mentioned the utilities and the
interstate transportation regulation
eventually the public and even the
knowledge classes became so aware of the
impediment that administrative
regulation the shackles that it was
placing on competition
in railroad and trucking and air
transport for instance but eventually
Congress deregulated so Congress could
in fact deregulate once the public
pressure gets strong enough
what can the executive do well you know
this president has been doing more to
take control of administrative agencies
than any president ever now that may be
because there's so much more to take aim
at but he required that agencies
repealed too old rules for each new one
he's required the he's made appointments
to a number of these boards that has
created more of an ideological balance
on them recently he threw the Justice
Department they said that agencies are
not going to be allowed to promulgate
major policy through mere statements
that they have to undergo the the
rulemaking procedure instead I don't
know precisely the breadth of that but
that would be a very important one they
have revised rules that there or
withdrawn some of the rules that were in
process during the previous
administration and said they were going
to reconsider them OMB officer Mulvaney
provided a statement of principles for
the CFPB of the consumer finance
Protection Board which is as was one of
the worst that could be adopted by every
agency and among his print is published
in The Wall Street Journal he says we
are government employees and we work for
the people that means everyone those who
use credit cards and those who provide
credits all of those people are part of
what makes this country great and all of
them deserve to be treated fairly by the
government it is not appropriate for
any government entity to push the
envelope when it comes into conflict
with our citizens on regulation it seems
that the people we regulate should have
the right to know what the rules are
before being charged with violating them
this means more formal rulemaking and we
will begin prioritizing in our
enforcement now if that kind of mission
statement were imposed on every
administrative agency it would make a
world of difference it would also
require the culture of the
administrative agencies to change and
finally the courts well I've told you
what's the negative as far as the courts
response to the administrative state but
I will say that a significant academic
challenge is now being made to the
threats that arbitrary administrative
rule posed to the separation of powers
and due process and the rule of law
professor Phillip hamburger wrote a very
well-known book called is administrative
law unconstitutional came out about four
years ago very long book very very
thorough scholarship it was it was
immediately greeted with horror and ad
hominem attacks by many of the so-called
administrative law experts in the
professorial community but it's been
cited favorably by Justice Thomas and
Justice Gorsuch so these idea their
ideas their scholarship that is going
after nearly every one of the principles
of deference that I told you about and
although I do not regard courts as the
ultimate solution for the problem of the
administrative state courts we'll have
to begin looking a lot more seriously at
the extent to which agencies are
properly applying the law that governs
them and finally there's the battle
of ideas and it was the Battle of ideas
that led to the creation of the
administrative state to begin with
although it came under somewhat false
colors but it will be the Battle of
ideas that will win in the end there are
a lot of professors there think tanks
were involved in this professor RJ pass
Trudeau here at Hillsdale has done quite
a lot of writing and effective
scholarship on this subject there are
many young academics who are being
trained in part by clerkships in the
federal courts that lead them into some
academic positions and I would urge that
such scholarship has to become
digestible to the public as well the
ultimate answer it seems to me you know
I always looked to Justice Scalia for
originalism and textualism and Ronald
Reagan who said there are no easy
answers but there are simple answers we
must have the courage to do what is
morally right thank you
thank you please raise your hand if you
have a question and it mics be brought
to you what is the judicial
justification for the agency being
prosecutor judge and jury and the
Catholic courts addressed that and
what's the pretext excuse me the
explanation that that is one of the
mysteries of the history of
administrative law and you have to look
at each part of that the I was just
reading articles recently about it and
it started with the Interstate Commerce
Commission which had the power to
regulate railroads but couldn't enforce
its orders and the public were getting
very upset you remember this is the time
when the small communities felt that
they were being cheated by the railroads
charging too high rate from the
agricultural areas into the cities and
so on the public became very disaffected
with this the Supreme Court was looking
closely and overruling a lot of attempts
by the ICC to engage in regulation and
the thought is that at some level the
court the court decided that regulators
ought to be able to look at the facts
underlying a decision and that they
ought to the courts ought to defer to
the way in which the regulator's had
found the facts now there are a lot of
issues that went sort of under the radar
and about the fundamental the non
delegation doctrine as I said got killed
that got killed largely because a couple
years after Schechter poultry may have
been or may have been at the same time
was the court Roosevelt's pork packing
plan and the membership Roosevelt
eventually appointed I think it well
maybe all members of the Supreme Court
but enough came on in a critical
two-year period that after Schechter
poultry the court
approving everything so the non
delegation doctrine died because
Roosevelt put all his new dealers on the
Supreme Court and it it never really
came back because it's it's a difficult
scholars have had and judges have had a
difficult time grasping it it's very you
know what is an appropriate delegation
and what isn't
I don't know that that'll be challenged
but a lot of this around the edges like
how do you make a rule how do you how do
you do
really what Congress ought to do is
write statutes that said we want you we
want you to regulate well it did in the
EPA pollutants and then it listed some
pollutants and I forget where there's a
catch phrase or not because there's so
Don many of those statutes but the
Supreme Court really went you know way
over over generous in interpreting that
law when it said that you could regulate
greenhouse gases okay and that means
that that gave the agency the courage if
you the brazenness to pursue you know
under this so meant last administration
the green house plans but Congress
didn't never specifically said that in
fact Congress would not have passed such
a law I wanted to tell you something the
EPA did since you mentioned them again
to a dear friend of ours and it shows
how these government agencies destroy
people this man runs a 75 year old
family business for five years he
ordered a chemical with all these forms
he needed to fill out was never told he
did anything wrong
after the fifth year the EPA shows up in
his office you are being you are
breaking the law you were buying more
chemicals than you need we're coming
after you for two years they made his
life a living hell they went to a
separate
Carrie's house in the dark with guns EPA
agents to coerce her into giving them
bad information about their boss he was
furious he finally after the stress was
unbelievable is in the newspaper he is a
college graduate his wife is on a
hospital board they give money to the
hospital he works with Junior
Achievement he's an Eagle Scout a good
citizen and employs 40 people but he
finally after he paid them a fine of
half a million dollars everything was
good he could order his chemical again
and he was good for two years however he
was a convicted felon so he had to get
rid of a civil war gun collection he had
to call a parole officer every week he
could not leave the country he had a
vacation home out of the country
couldn't do anything he was he's a you
know this is ridiculous two years later
they show up again they find another
thing that was totally stupid they put
him through the same crap again
excuse my words I'm he's a very good
friend and this is very upsetting
two years later they come back again
this is the third time now our friend is
in the hospital he is so ill the doctors
do not know what is wrong with them but
I'll tell you it is the stress that our
government has put on him they are
killing him his wife is falling apart
the the man said to us once I might
expect this in Russia but not in the
United States they are destroying my
business my husband wants to get him a
pardon if he can we tried under the when
Bush was still in office and our
congressman who was here last night said
it was too late couldn't do anything
under the Obama administration what can
we do to help somebody like this before
he dies so he doesn't die a convicted
felon all I know of is the presidential
pardon power I'm sorry I mean that's you
know that that ought to be a matter of
great public concern again I mean you
know when we're the only the kinds of
cases we get before the supreme court or
before our court are not those cases
because those people can't afford
the sophisticated legal talent but it's
required the psychic case was supposed
to avert some of that so I don't know
when it when when your friends problems
arose but I agree it's unaccountable
political power and yeah it's
unaccountable political power in in the
hands of one agency a few years back the
Supreme Court decided to change the
meaning of the word marriage now all the
laws are actually written in words if
the Supreme Court can change the meaning
of one word do any of the laws actually
mean anything anymore well as you know
that was a 5-4 decision and the Supreme
Court can do a lot of things with five
votes and I am NOT standing here to
justify everything they do if they
adhere to the principles that Justice
Scalia stood for the Justice Thomas
stands for that Justice Alito stands for
the God willing at least two other
members of the Supreme Court stand for
that kind of thing wouldn't happen you
know we that's the downside of life
tenure for judges but the point of
Justice Scalia's jurisprudence and
philosophy was the judges in our society
have one right and one duty and that is
to say what the law is and and the best
and only evidence of the law is the text
of the law so a lot fall and whenever
you read about a Supreme Court decision
you know the press reports them in terms
of who won and who lost but you can
always say what was the law and that
ought to give you the answer and it
usually does just one more question
I thank you I'm a layman not a lawyer
but I've actually read the chevron
decision and found it very puzzling and
I wonder maybe if you could shed some
light on if you have a situation where a
law could reasonably be interpreted to
mean either A or B I mean how can a
citizen be expected to know what that
law means and why didn't the courts just
kick it back to Congress and say you
can't tell tell us pass a law tell us
whether it means a or B well that's a
principle called vagueness and the
courts have been very reluctant to
strike down laws as being unduly vague I
don't remember
precisely what the statute was in
Chevron but it was one of those economic
regulatory statutes let's say it was
let's say it was the Clean Water Act and
it said that waters of the United States
now if you look to the history of waters
of the United States the federal
government had control over navigable
waters of the United States which
certainly did not include most you know
inland marshes it did not include
seasonal streams and that kind of thing
and the court trying to interpret that
gave an it made a stab at it about ten
years ago in the case called Rapanos
that didn't quite solve the question
although it did they were in that case
the EPA was trying to regulate a marsh
that was totally inland not collect
connected to anything if I recall
correctly and they said no that's not
waters of the United States within the
federal purview it could States could
regulate it but not the federal
government
but the administrators came back and you
say very very mean think of it think of
a culvert right a storm sewer is that
waters of the United States well it
depends on what regulator you ask and
and the Supreme Court it is an EM it's
an ambiguous unless you look at it in a
purely historical sense you could say
it's an
and that's where people divide an
interpretation you can either look at
something according to the dictionaries
according to the context and the history
or you can just take the take the words
as if you're you know a Martian coming
down from outer space looking at this
strange language waters of the United
States oh well there's Jones's backyard
in Houston it's sort of damp like
everything in Houston that must be
waters of the United States so that's
where the ambiguity is and then the
question under Chevron is whether it is
a reasonable interpretation under
Justice Scalia the Supreme Court did in
fact look more closely at the statute
and it looked more closely at
reasonableness but the lower courts and
even the Supreme Court are deeply
divided they're not particularly they're
not consistent you know the courts I
mean the courts for a long time have
acted as if we are the ultimate
guardians of the people's liberty and if
I had one sombre thing to end with today
it would be that you can't trust the
courts either
yep well and I'll say it's not that
we're not trying and that we're not
dedicated but the law is imperfect and
judges are imperfect